MIKE BRANCH: I think
one of the things,
if I were to rewind five years
and play things over again--
and it seems very, very simple.
It does.
It's very intuitive,
but I think this one
thing would go a long way for
anybody starting their journey.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRUNO AZIZA: Hi, everyone.
I'm Bruno Aziza, and welcome
to another great episode
of Data Journeys.
This is a place that we come
to learn from leaders in data
and analytics, leaders who
have achieved amazing results
and growth,
significant outcomes,
and are willing to spend
some time with us to share
their lessons, their dos and
don'ts, and their stories.
And so today, I have the
pleasure of talking with Mike.
Mike is Vice President of
Data Analytics at Geotab.
He was a CEO before of
a company whose team
was acquired by Geotab.
He's an amazing
entrepreneur and has
achieved very amazing things
over the last five years.
So we want to hear from him.
Mike, thank you so much
for taking the time
to talk to us today.
Let's get started.
What does Geotab do first?
MIKE BRANCH: Yeah, no.
Pleasure being here, Bruno.
So Geotab, we're the world's
largest commercial telematics
provider.
What that means
effectively is we
work with a lot of
commercial fleets.
So we've got a device that plugs
into the onboard diagnostic
port of vehicles, over two
million commercially connected
vehicles, and voted
number one by ABI
Research across the globe.
And we provide all
of our customers
with a number of
insights, everything
from safe driving to fleet
optimization, better routing.
And we have this wide
network of partners,
and we've created this platform
to allow our partners to help
our customers to build some
amazing products on top
of the ecosystem.
And then from all
of this data, it's
my team that really
looks at this data
and figures how do we
drive further insight
for our customers from
this vast amount of data
that's coming into the
ecosystem on a daily basis?
BRUNO AZIZA: So two million
commercial vehicles,
that's 40 billion
data points a day.
We're talking a lot of data,
a lot of changing data.
So take us through the use
cases that are deployed today.
MIKE BRANCH: So we've got a
number of different use cases.
So we've got about 40,000
to 50,000 customers
that are kicking around there.
And the problem with that
is that you have so many
disparate use cases, right?
I've got customers who are
running fleets of size one
to over 100,000 in
different verticals.
Some are municipal vehicles.
Some are vehicles that
do last mile delivery.
Some are construction vehicles.
So it's just such a wide array.
So what we've done
is we try to look
at what we can create
broadly that will
help our ecosystem
deliver more impact.
And one of the areas that
we've done a lot of work in
is predictive maintenance.
Picture a vehicle
driving around.
You want to be notified
if there's something
wrong with that vehicle.
And the instance
that we looked at,
we actually asked one of
our largest customers,
what is the single
biggest problem for you?
And they said, it's
the electrical system.
That's the biggest
problem for us.
And it's not the
cost of a battery,
because batteries are
super cheap in cars.
But it's the cost
of the downtime
whilst that vehicle's
on the side of the road.
So we looked at how
can we better predict
when a battery is going
to fail in a vehicle
to help this customer out?
And so we did that,
and after, actually it
was a couple of years of work.
We developed all the
pipelines that were required,
looked at all the
feature engineering.
We developed some
predictive models,
and we actually developed
predictive models
to clean the data, as well too.
Because as the data is
coming into the ecosystem,
you look at something like
cranking voltage, which
is one of the features
we use to figure out
whether a battery is
going to fail or not,
and there's noise in
that data as well, too.
So you have to establish
ML algorithms that
look at bad cranking events
versus good cranking events.
And so net net at
the end of the day,
this ended up saving this one
customer millions of dollars
a year.
And as a result, we worked
closely with the customer
but have now started
to deploy that
across the entire ecosystem so
that we can issue these, OK, we
think your battery is going
to fail in this vehicle.
You should really check it out.
And then what the customers
can do and the partners can do
is they can take that
insight and integrate it
into any other
downstream maintenance
applications for reminders
and these kinds of things.
BRUNO AZIZA:
Predictive maintenance
is going to be common to a
lot of folks listening to us.
And when we're talking
about lots of data here,
I think the other
dimension is you're
working with a lot of
real time data, right?
I think you've got about
11 petabytes of data
you're working with, real time
streams going into your system.
So what are, beyond
predictive maintenance,
what are the other
use cases you've
deployed using the
Google technology?
MIKE BRANCH: They're so
varied, and we've got a team.
I've got a strong team.
We were about 65 on the
team right now doing
all sorts of things.
But one of the areas
where I'm especially proud
of this year in specific
is some of the work
that we did with
regards to COVID,
and I'll explain how
that came into play.
So of course, when
everything hit in March,
and the world kind of
stopped, we look to ourselves
and we thought, how
can we better help?
What can we do?
And we thought, you know what,
we're in a position right now--
and we used that kind of
Johns Hopkins dashboard that
showed how the countries
across the world
was faring when it
came to COVID cases.
We used that as a
bit of a litmus test
for what we could do.
And so we looked at commercial
transportation recovery.
And we said, you know what, with
two million commercial vehicles
across the globe, we could be
a benchmark for our customers
and for the public sector to
better understand and make
informed policy decisions as
it relates to recovery, not
only within a country but
by sectors within a country.
So how is the construction
sector faring versus pre-COVID?
How is the oil and
gas sector faring?
How is transportation logistics?
Really important indicators.
And so we use a number of
different Google technologies
for that.
The data was made available
through Geotab Ignition, which
is our open data, aggregate
data portal, which
is fueled by Google BigQuery.
And these aggregates,
what we did
is we made it freely available
for everyone to access.
And we created and
established connectors.
And one of the most interesting
ones I think was with Deloitte
did with that.
So Deloitte connected
up to that data
set, which we updated on a
daily basis, this high frequency
data, and pulled it into their
economic recovery dashboard.
And within, I think the first
week was about 160,000 views
of the dashboard.
And I think what that
instilled is the need
to look at alternative data
sources at a high frequency
to be able to enable
policy and decision making.
And so we started to
see a lot more interest,
not looking at necessarily
traditional means,
but looking at things
like economic recovery.
So I think a really great
example, and the tools
that we used, Google BigQuery,
of course, to service the data.
We're using behind the
scenes a whole whackload
of other things.
If you want, I can
talk to some of--
would it makes sense to talk
to some of that now too, Bruno?
Yeah?
BRUNO AZIZA: Well,
I think it would,
because you're using Dataflow
as well in the background.
Before we go there, you have
so many interesting use cases.
I want to hear
about the third one
around the corridor
analysis, which
I think a lot of people
that are traveling
will be able to relate to.
Tell us more about what
you're doing there.
MIKE BRANCH: Yeah.
This one is exceptionally
interesting, too.
And keep in mind, our core
customers are fleet customers.
But we believe that through
the aggregate use of this data,
there's a lot of assistance that
we can be to the public sector
from an infrastructure
perspective.
And this one came
by the way of what
we did with the Regional
Transportation Commission
in Las Vegas.
And they were
looking for, again,
this high frequency
way of looking
at corridor analysis
and signal timing
to lessen congestion
within the arteries
in and around Las Vegas.
And traditionally
how it's done is
there's a lot of physical,
manual deployments
of infrastructure.
And we said, we think we
can do this with just data.
So what we did is we
first devised models
to figure out what an
intersection actually
looks like.
And that sounds like
a trivial thing.
Well, isn't it just a
point on the map, Mike?
Well, no, it's a
little beyond that.
Because you have to
understand the exact geometry
of an intersection,
as it relates
to vehicles traveling
through there,
to be able to provide
these metrics,
if we look at corridor
analysis and signal timing.
So we developed machine
learning models.
This is part of
the intersection.
Oh, this was a guy
that's fixing something
at the intersection,
a light, or sitting
at a parking lot that is very
close to the intersection.
So now, if I'm the
traffic engineer in Vegas,
I can pull up this
application in near real time
and have a fantastic idea of
what signal timing looks like.
You can choose a whole
corridor along an avenue,
and you get the same diagrams
that a traffic engineer would
be used to seeing, but on a high
frequency basis, in real time,
without any deployment, but
the vehicles moving around.
And again, all aggregate,
all privacy compliant,
which is another big
component of this approach.
BRUNO AZIZA: So this is precise.
It's real time.
It's accessible by everyone.
It's just these are
amazing use cases.
And I do want to drill
into the products, as well
as their learning.
So as you're deploying
these products-- and here,
we're talking about BigQuery
and Dataflow and a host
of other technologies.
What are the things that
you've learned, maybe the do's?
Let's start with
the positive news,
which is which are the
things that everybody
needs to go out and
do, when they get
started on their journey?
MIKE BRANCH: I think
one of the things,
if I were to rewind five years
and play things over again,
and it seems very, very simple.
It does.
It's very intuitive,
but I think this one
thing would go a
long way for anybody
starting their journey now.
It's just treat data as you
would any other product.
Right?
Oftentimes, data is a
byproduct of products,
and people look at
it in that fashion.
But if you don't treat
data as a product,
you end up with
issues downstream.
Right?
So what do I mean by that?
Well, I need to make sure you
have proper version control
everything.
The lineage, I need to
understand the flows
from one data set to the next
across my entire ecosystem.
The notion of data
operations, as well too,
is critically important.
So somebody's
created the data set.
They leave the company.
What happens to it?
Where does that
institutional knowledge go?
So it's all of these things
that you would think about
if you were
developing a product,
but sometimes go by the wayside
if you're thinking about data.
So I think the notion
of treating data
as a product is
absolutely essential.
One of the biggest things
that we've learned--
and if you're a data
scientist and you're not
familiar with BigQuery,
you should be.
Because it is one of the
most instrumental tools
that we leverage
and use at Geotab.
And traditionally, you
look at data science,
you're doing a lot of
scripting in Python or R,
and that's where you're doing
a lot of your workloads.
Look at BigQuery for doing it.
We have, I think, an
amazing talk that's
done by one of our data
scientists, Daniel Lewis,
and it talks about
just do it in SQL.
Right?
And so there's so
much power that
can be had by just
leveraging BigQuery
for these massive workloads.
And the geospatial analysis
that comes with those tools,
absolutely incredible.
So don't feel like you have
to do everything in Python.
Let BigQuery do more
for you, because it can.
And then the third
thing, because this
is where people
will get tripped up,
if they go too far along a
path, have a tight integration
with your privacy office.
Because every single data
product that you develop
needs to be privacy
compliant, and that
isn't easy in the
lens of data nowadays.
There are so many different
categories of data.
Legislation just changing every
day on a state-by-state level,
and to understand the
implications to have
a tight alignment
with data and privacy
is absolutely crucial in getting
these products out the door.
BRUNO AZIZA: This is amazing.
And you do have an amazing team.
I look at the work Dan's doing.
I was reading this
weekend the work
that Terence is
doing on publishing
some of the learnings on
machine learning and so forth.
You really have an amazing team
that does great work with data.
Now, let's talk about
the flip side of that.
What are some of the mistakes
that people should avoid,
and what you've learned
that you probably
wouldn't do again if you
were just getting started?
MIKE BRANCH: R&D is
crucially important.
It's vital to creating new
innovation, new product.
I think we spend a
lot of time in R&D,
but we have to learn
how to extract ourselves
from that at some point in
time and know when what you've
developed is good enough.
And so often we
think, oh, you know
what, I'm shooting for that
98% accuracy on that model.
Well guess what,
the customer would
be thrilled to
have something that
has 90% accuracy,
depending on the product
that you're releasing.
And so what we've
found has helped
is having this notion of
an applied data scientist.
Right?
So somebody who sits
between product and data who
understands the data world
and can talk to product world
as well too, right?
And says, OK, R&D team, we
think that what you have
there is ready to
take to production.
Let's put it into a pipeline
and let's get going.
Otherwise you end up burning
cycles in too much R&D.
And then allow them to continue
on with further refinement
for sure.
And then of course, I'd say
there's an easy tendency,
because BQ, BigQuery, is so
easy to leverage and use,
people will just dump things
into BigQuery, and it creates--
I wrote an article a
few years back about,
don't create these data swamps.
Right?
Because data lake, well
and good, but data swamp
is not something that you want.
And it's easy, very easy--
oh, just push it to BQ.
We'll figure it out later.
No, have a
consolidated approach.
It all comes down, again,
to that treating data
as a product.
And then the last thing, before
you even touch on any modeling,
whether it be
analytic or ML based,
make sure you truly
understand your data
and the nuances in that data.
How is it collected?
How does it change?
When we're dealing with IoT
devices and firmware updates,
what happens when firmware
is updated to the data
that you're collecting?
Right?
If you are in
predictive maintenance,
getting a deep understanding for
the mechanical system behind it
or the electrical system.
It's fundamental to understand
what happens when a vehicle is
turning over and cranking,
so that you understand
how you can construct your
features to further develop
your model.
So a lot of times people
just jump to the model
and think that the data will--
and there are some amazing tools
to allow you to extract insight
from data, and that's being more
democratized by Google as well
too.
But you have to
fundamentally understand
what the data is all
about before you can
continue to the modeling phase.
BRUNO AZIZA: Well, Mike,
this has been amazing.
I learned a ton, and I
wish I could continue
talking to you for hours.
I learned about
the best practice
on treating data as a product.
This means think about version
control, data operations,
lineage.
Don't think about data as
a byproduct of the work
that you're doing.
And of course, this concept
of applied data science
that I hope a lot of people
here will take and apply
at their own company.
Again, thank you so
much for taking the time
to talk to us today, Mike.
And for everybody else, if you
want to hear more stories just
like this, make sure that you
click on the link down below.
Until next time,
I'm Bruno Aziza.
[MUSIC PLAYING]